france gall bonsoir invité parce que
vous allez chanter à bercy dans le grand
merci oui au début du mois de juin
figurez vous que je vais faire bercy en
effet l'antenne fait rire les reverser
oui on va découvrir l'une des chansons
que vous allez chanter que maryse
richard et pme la roue tourne et cet
après midi j'ai d'ailleurs la même tenue
des auteurs greffe les coeurs et
où des millions de gens se connaissent
eux sinon
et
jeux 2d maillage est pas complète mais
les dés
les jets
b
bon je te donne c'est normal que je le
connaisse pas les paroles sais pas c'est
une chanson de michel donc je connais
pas les paroles par coeur encore michel
michel berger le titre de cette chanson
ces quelques mots d'amour c'est une de
ses chansons les plus connues on devait
faire devait faire des chansons à lui et
moi je vais faire
voilà et ça me fait vraiment plaisir de
pouvoir faire ses chansons j'aime tout
donc je pourrais même faire celle de
johnny il y avait mis dans cette chanson
il manque quelqu'un près de moi oui mais
ça a été écrit par michel ya dix ans
donc le problème c'est plus justement
avec cette ou ces textes il ya des
chansons que je peux pas mettre à cause
du texte bien qu'elle ait été écrite
avant sa disparition alors donc il faut
que je fasse des choix il ya les rdv de
force intérieure qui apparaît
l'extérieur n'ont trouvé gentil
admirable vous faites comment dans cette
force vos enfants et bien je vais vous
dire je sais pas je vis au jour le jour
au quotidien je fais des choses qui
m'intéressent qui m'amuse je me plonge
dans la musique ça c'est vraiment mais
respiration et je m'amuse beaucoup j'ai
beaucoup de bonheur à préparer ce
spectacle et ça va passer sur scène et
je pense que ça va être un spectacle
évidemment très différent de tout ce que
j'ai fait puisque je le fais salle mais
mais j'ai énormément de bonheur à le
faire et puis oui mes enfants évidemment
mes enfants sont tellement là est
tellement
intéressé par ce que je fais il était
très inquiet à l'idée que je fasse bercy
tout seul mais tu vas pas y arriver et
peur tu vas pas y arriver ils m'ont dit
au début et non ça ne fait pas parce
vous a l'impression d'avoir changé on
attend souvent d'une artiste d'une femme
ou d'un homme qui chante qui le rapporte
uniquement la distraction la gaieté le
rire et j'ai l'impression qu'à une
dimension nouvelle qui peut être pas
changé nous épaulent ça a changé ça ça
c'était bien c'était après la guerre qui
chantait des chansons de distraction
maintenant depuis un bon nombre d'années
la chanson véhicules autre chose
on peut ne plus être comme vous le dites
comme vous le chantez superficiel et les
jeux watson c'est tellement agréable de
l'être mais c'est très difficile en
effet bercy début juin real devant des
milliers de fans ça me fait pas peur un
b non puisque ils vont pas venir pour
m'embêter viennent parce qu'ils ont
envie de venir parce qu'ils mènent tout
ça c'est de l'amour à prendre merci
merci